- [Narrator] This bottle, this brand.
Unique and busy, yet simple and standard.
You might've seen it.
You might even use it.
But have you ever read it?
The Dr. Bronner
Brand is the top selling
organic soap company in North America.
And if you look closely at the label,
you'll see quotes from Jesus,
Einstein, George Washington,
you name it, you'll also read
a lot about the moral ABC.
The brainchild of Dr. Emmanuel Bronner,
the founder of Dr. Bronner's Magic Soaps.
Born into a Jewish family in Germany,
he immigrated to Milwaukee in 1929
and worked as a consultant
for various soap companies.
But his real passion was philosophy.
He had a vision for world peace,
and he called it moral ABC.
Its mission read,
- [Emmanuel] "In all we
do, let us be generous,
fair and loving to Spaceship
Earth and all its inhabitants.
"For we're all-one or none, All-One."
- [Narrator] Basically he
wanted people to set aside
their religious and ethnic differences
to find common ground.
During WWII, Bronner began lecturing
and spreading his vision
for peace and unity,
and he started drawing crowds.
(cheering)
In 1947, during one of his lecture tours,
Bronner was arrested for
giving a public speech
without a permit, he wound
up in a mental institution.
He escaped, and he made his
way to Southern California
where he declared himself a doctor, rabbi,
and alleged that he was Einstein's nephew.
It was during this lecture
tour that Bronner began
giving his family's soap away.
He quickly realized
people were only coming
for the free soap, and
leaving before the lecture
so Bronner started printing his scriptures
and sticking them onto the bars.
And just like that, Dr.
Bronner's Magic Soap was born.
(jazzy music)